so we're in the blackhole laboratory
what you're looking at that's an analog
rotating black hole
as a first step we fill up the spacing
here in the back
we put water in there and then we also
put what's called fluorescent dye it
makes your fingers dirty it's actually
sort of orangey but then it takes a blue
part of the spectrum of the light and
converts blue into green there are about
2000 liters of water in there if you
follow me here we have two walls which
we can open and control how much is
going through each inlet we have two
inlets in our tongue we feed in the
water from this side
and also from the other side
and so we have this rectangular tank
and we fill in the water this way
so by feeding it in this particular way
you give it angular momentum
and then what we have we have a hole in
the center these are exchangeable center
holes the water is coming in
and because of the way we feed it i
start spinning and it's draining in the
center so it's a stationary draining
fluid flow or just a basta vortex flow
so this is not a black hole for me or
you
that's a black hole for small
excitations in this system
so if you look at sound waves or little
ripples on the surface this is what we
are interested they have a certain
propagation speed
and if you set up fluid flows where the
background velocity of the flow
exceeds the propagation speed of the
little ripples you can set up what's
called a analog horizons so suppose
you're in a one dimensional fluid flow
and you look at small excitations
and they can be moving up or downstream
of the flow but if you have a region
where the fluid flow exceeds the speed
of your little ripples on the free
surface
then it means that if you are in this
region you cannot propagate against the
flow
so let's say you would be in this region
where the flow is super critical so
faster than the perturbations i am in
the region where it's sub-critical and
we want to exchange information only
using the little ripples on the free
surface
then i can send information to you
downstream
but you cannot send any information
upstream because the flow is faster
going downstream so that nothing can
counter propagate
so in the region where exactly the two
speeds the perturbation speed of the
little ripple on the surface and the
background follow equal that's your
analog black hole horizon so this is a
bit of a more difficult system so it's
not one-dimensional it has a
two-dimensional velocity component
meaning it has a radial component the
water is training and it has an angular
momentum the moment the water is
spinning and what you can see there are
two horizons
and i don't know if i can visualize it i
can try so you can see i'm looking for
two there are two horizons in there
there's one when the total velocity of
the fluid flow so radial and angular
momentum exceed the little ripples on
the surface and this is what we call an
ergo horizon so any fluctuation that
comes inside this ergo horizon cannot
counter propagate to the fluid flow it
gets dragged along it's called frame
dragging but it can still escape
there is another point where the radial
velocity only the radial component is
faster than the little ripple on the
surface and that's called the analog
event horizon so if you're in a flow
here you see nothing special is happen
right
perturbations can go in each direction
if i'm going to a point
where the background flow
exceeds the perturbation seed you see a
little uh cone opening in the back
and this cone opens
if
uh and only if the background flow
exceeds
the speed of the perturbation i don't
know if you can see it can you see it so
and now if i manage and i need to now go
up all the way here and then you see the
cone nicely here
you see how this cone tilts more and
more and more
and at some point this cone
tilts completely inside and once this
cone is not like this it contains like
this that's where the effective black
hole horizon is and between these two
horizons here there are some very
interesting scattering processes
happening a big part of that is to set
up this background flow in the best way
for the purposes of of mimicking
rotating black holes when i say that i
have something very particular in mind
and that's a very bizarre process that
happens around rotating black holes so a
rotating black hole has at least it has
to have a mass and an angular momentum
what can happen because you have these
two horizons you have this ergosphere
and you have this black hole horizon
and you have this frame dragging region
so if something comes into this region a
small perturbation it scatters with this
black hole
and it extracts a little bit of angular
momentum from the rotating black hole
and so this is what's called super
radiant scattering process you can come
out with more energy loosely speaking
and this energy comes from the angular
momentum of the rotating black hole in
our case analog rotating black hole what
is really interesting is because when
you have a real life setup and even a
very controlled real-life setup you have
to come up with ways to actually detect
this effect because they're very small
and also this is perhaps a really
old-style fluid flow experiments people
have been experimenting with for 100
years probably
what they haven't gotten back then and
what we have now is the technology so
what we're using is
uh top of the art cameras with a very
high frame rate per seconds and a very
high spatial resolution we're hunting
for the very small
not so small like the gravitational
waves but it's still very small and i
can tell you how small if you look at
that flow and i'm in a regime where this
analogy should hold i'm looking at small
excitations on the top like that
i can stimulate them for example these
are not very small but it's better to
see it like that and usually what you
want is that this little amplitude of
the sky
that it is small compared to the height
of the fluid flow
so
what we want to send in is a wave with
an amplitude of a millimeter the change
is tiny so the increase in the amplitude
is at best a tense so 0.1 millimeter
what we really want to see are tiny
changes in the amplitude of those waves
what i want to see is when the wave
scatters with this uh vortex which is
analog rotating black hole that it
increases energy by interacting with
this effective rotating black hole
it gains energy and that's exactly what
should happen around astrophysical
rotating black holes an astrophysical
rotating black hole loses its angular
momentum and one way of losing it is
through this super radiant scattering
process so whatever comes
it scatters with it and it can actually
transfer some of the angular momentum
from the rotating black hole onto for
example gravitational wave or other
objects but this is more a test of
principle to study this effect which has
not been seen before in a very
controlled way and it's true we are
sending in or we are going to improve
this much further that's just the first
step people usually like it because it
is very hands-on one of the huge
challenges to overcome
was to measure the free surface over a
relatively large area and you can see
the area now
indicated by this light where the bright
green is so and what you see above here
what we developed here is an air water
interface sensor
and what it does it projects in the
middle there is a blue led light and it
projects a random pattern
uh changing with 500 frames per second
onto this free surface
and then you have two cameras on the
edges of the sensor
and then what you do you take also 500
images per second the first step you
need to do you take a series of images
to find out which points corresponds to
the same physical point in these two
images and you look at a correlation and
it works exactly in a way if you wish if
you have the eyes
you take from everything two images but
your brain converts it into one so this
is what we do and with this information
we can reconstruct the free surface here
on the screen you see the reconstructed
image through this process it's a little
bit better than our eyes because i get
exact amplitudes here you see you can
see all the waves coming in and you can
see how this waves scatter here and how
they get deformed i have to say that we
started a year ago
so before that was a storage room what
we have put together in one year
i think it's uh it's really incredible
we have great support here so what we
are doing right now we are testing we're
testing how good is the center so this
is a nice stage it's also a little bit
of a nerve wracking stage
because we could be very close to see
this effect or we could maybe be a year
maybe two i don't think i hope not but
we could be
one doesn't know when when we will see
it so
it's an exciting time
intricate link between the matter and
the space time just imagine
trying to imagine these two huge objects
what they're doing to the matter to the
space time around it as they and the
space tank must be going oh my god